after days of growing pressure the u.s.
is grounding all Boeing 737 max planes
aircraft involved in a deadly crash in
Ethiopia the Federal Aviation
Administration ordered us airlines to
remove the popular passenger jet from
service temporarily but it gave no end
date for the move the decision followed
bans in dozens of other countries a lot
of people were waiting for this decision
and the FAA says the decision is based
on new information about the crash of an
Ethiopian Boeing 737 max Sunday that
killed 157 people the black boxes
arrived in Paris overnight for analysis
Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan National
Airport outside Washington where some of
the grounded max Jets are actually
parked right now Chris good morning good
morning those 737 max planes will stay
parked indefinitely until the FAA lifts
this order now once the decision came
down the 72 737 max planes that are
operated by US airlines were told to
stay where they were or finish the
flight they were on now the US airlines
are scrambling to make up about 280
flights a day those planes handled
facility from a landed in Phoenix on
board a Southwest Airlines Boeing 737
max Wednesday her flight from Houston
took off just minutes before President
Trump announced the FAA stijn to ground
all 737 max planes nationwide the safety
of the American people at all people is
our paramount concern the US was among
the last of more than 40 countries to
temporarily ban the max federal
regulators and airlines had been facing
increasing pressure to ground the plane
following Sunday's deadly crash of
Ethiopian Airlines flight 302 the second
737 max eight to crash in less than five
months on Tuesday the FAA said it had no
basis to ground the max but on Wednesday
the agency reversed course saying it
received new satellite data that showed
the flight track of flight 302 was
similar to that of the lion Air Boeing
737 that crashed off of Indonesia in
October both planes struggled to
maintain altitude in the minutes after
takeoff evidence found at the crash
scene in Africa showed additional
similarities your grass
pounding a class of aircraft based on
nothing but political pressure former
FAA assistant administrator Scott
Brenner says the agency should have
waited for data from the Ethiopian Jets
black boxes before making its decision
they have always been a very cooperative
data-driven group and now that seems to
have kind of gone to the wayside
Ethiopian investigators have now sent
the black boxes to Paris to be analyzed
nearly three days after they were
recovered from the crash site it's
negligent in my view former NTSB
investigator Jeff Gazeta says the
readout should have happened much sooner
time is of the essence more you wait the
more you increase the exposure to a very
specific hazard Ethiopian investigators
yesterday asked the Germans to analyze
the boxes but they didn't have the
proper software so it was on to France
American Airlines says they will start
shuttling some of the 737 maxes without
passengers to their bases today Boeing
says it is confident in the safety of
the aircraft but supports the grounding
out of an abundance of caution Gail well
we'll all feel better when we have some
answers here thank you very much Chris